pardon ok vous pouvez me dire pourquoi
je suis arrêté monsieur pourquoi je suis
arrêté monsieur la vidéo a fait le tour
du monde
omar jimenez envoyé spécial de la chaîne
cnn est arrêtée menottée en plein direct
alors qu'ils couvrent les émeutes à
minneapolis
la chaîne américaine dénonce rapidement
une atteinte grave à la liberté de la
presse un journaliste de cnn est son
équipe de production ont été arrêtés ce
matin à minneapolis en faisant leur
travail malgré s'être identifié une
violation manifeste du premier
amendement
si le premier amendement de la
constitution américaine garantit en
effet la liberté de la presse
sur le terrain c'est autre chose
quarante trois reporters ont été arrêtés
dans des manifestations aux états unis
depuis 2017 et l'investiture de donald
trump
depuis le début des manifestations anti
police des dizaines de reporters ont été
prises à partie par les forces de
l'ordre certains directement visés par
des tirs de balles en caoutchouc ou de
gaz lacrymogène
c'est le cas par exemple de molly et
n'essaie fisc journaliste au los angeles
times elle a couvert les conflits en
irak en afghanistan les émeutes raciales
de 2014 à ferguson ait jamais dit elle
la police ne lui a jusqu'ici tiré dessus
oui a été identifié comme journaliste et
ils ont tiré sur nous des cartouches de
gaz lacrymogène
j'ai été touché à la jambe nous avons
demandé où allons nous allons nous ils
n'ont pas répondu
ils ne nous ont pas diriger
ils ont juste tiré sur nous un
témoignage loin d'être isolé un
correspondant de cbs michael george a
pour sa part rapporté que son équipe
avait été visée par des balles en
caoutchouc alors qu'elle se trouvait
loin du franc regardez cela fait 15 ans
que je couvre des manifestations à
travers les états unis
c'est la première fois que je vois la
police est ciblé la presse activement et
intentionnellement avec des balles en
caoutchouc des lacrymogènes et des
arrestations
ce sont des scènes qui rappellent la
chine ou l'iran nous restons déterminés
à montrer au pays ce qui se passe sur le
terrain
à louiseville dans le kentucky c'est une
jeune journaliste de la chaîne locale
wave fraigneau ce qui à son tour a été
ciblé quatre lignes restent intervenait
elle aussi en direct
ils savent à genoux fait tirer dessus et
kylie sava balles de caoutchouc
ce sont des balles de poivre qui sont
ils tirent sur notre équipe directement
sur nos pourquoi font-ils ça me tire sur
le caméraman je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas ils ne savent pas qu'ils sont en
face de la caméra à liverchies
journaliste vedette de la chaîne
ms nbc a été touché par une balle en
caoutchouc en plein direct lui aussi est
alors qu'il se trouvait à une bonne
distance d'un rassemblement à
minneapolis
il a d'abord cru à un tir involontaire
avant de se raviser
quand après avoir levé les mains en
l'air et crier médias les policiers lui
ont répondu on s'en fiche
avant de tirer une seconde fois les gars
je suis fait tirer dessus attendez mais
le cas le plus grave c'est certainement
celui de linda tirado à minneapolis
cette photographe indépendante du
tennessee a laissé tomber ses lunettes
de protection un court instant
avant d'être atteinte par une balle de
caoutchouc au visage à l'hôpital elle a
appris qu'elle ne recouvre aurait
probablement pas la vue de l'oeil gauche
l institut fried a mauvaise presse et le
site bell incat indiquent avoir recensé
une cinquantaine d' exemples de
journalistes américains je cite à gré
c'est par les forces de l'ordre et des
violences sans précédent contre les
journalistes que reporters sans
frontières attribue à donald trump la
diabolisation des médias car entretenu
donald trump pendant des années porte
aujourd'hui ses fruits
rsf avait alerté sur les conséquences de
cette flagrante hostilité envers les
médias et nous assistons aujourd'hui à
un déchaînement de violence sans
précédent contre les journalistes aux
états unis depuis son élection donald
trump s'attaquent régulièrement aux
médias le président américain les accuse
de déformer la vérité voire de fabriquer
de fausses informations dans le but de
lui nuire
le locataire de la maison blanche
qualifie même la presse d' ennemis du
peuple